Speaker 1: You know, we've become accustomed to
sort of lurid anecdotes of all kinds being told at
rightwing rallies, oh, this undocumented immigrant
did this thing or that thing or the other thing,
and sort of used to the bizarre, craven political
advantage of many of these Republicans. They are
now up against such an example themselves
because of a guy that is being dubbed the
MAGA masturbator. I. I don't know what to tell
you guys. A Republican Arizona candidate has
been caught masturbating outside of a preschool
and the story is absolutely bonkers. HuffPost is
reporting. Arizona Republican candidate arrested
for allegedly masturbating in a truck near a
preschool. It's in none other than the infamous
Maricopa County, Arizona, where officials say it's
too late to remove the the alleged perpetrator,
Randy Coffman, from the ballot in the race for a
college district board. Dozens of you emailing me
about this. The story is roughly as follows again,
as reported by Huffington Post. Coffman was
arrested on October 4th but suspended his campaign
earlier this week following reports of his arrest.
He was running for the governing board of the
Maricopa County Community College District and
was allegedly caught masturbating by the county's
community college police. I left up, Coffman said
to an officer during the arrest, according to the
police report, which is quite a document which
you can find online and read. The report says.
The incident started when an officer approached
Coffman's parked vehicle and saw that he had his
pants down. I'm not going to read it exactly
as it is written, but basically the officer
was able to ascertain by visual observation
of the individual's genitalia that there was
manipulation taking place. And it was all in
view of a nearby bicyclist and a preschool
where little kids were playing outside.
When confronted, according to the officer,
Coffman apologized and said, I'm sorry I left up.
I'm really stressed, really, really stressed. And
then said, Are you going to put that in the
report, which indeed the officer did? Yikes.
Don't you see how alarming that is? The
officer responded. There are children nearby,
people passing on bikes and in cars where
they can look and see what you're doing.
Notably in a Facebook post from May, Coffman said
he wanted, quote, Our children protected from the
progressive left. Kaufman was charged with public
indecency. But 12 News in Phenix reported that
Kaufman could also face a possible felony charge
because of his proximity to the preschool. So
listen, what is the story? Here is the story that
Republicans endorse this stuff. No, it's not. And
one of the things that Republicans have been
insisting upon and we saw I mean, I can't even
name all of the people that did it. Carrie Lake
has done it. Marjorie Taylor GREENE has done it.
There's so many. They love to say the Democrats
are the party of pedophilia and child abuse and
all of these different things. And of course, they
don't even have examples of it. Here we have an
actual MAGA Republican who is caught doing exactly
what they love to say the left welcomes, and now
they don't want to say it has anything to do with
their party. I'm willing to concede that this is
an individual actor. But what we can't continue
allowing them to do is to insist without evidence
that the left is the party of all this demonic
cabal of pedophiles. And this that the other thing
without evidence, when this is not the only story
like it that we find about Republicans. I'm not.
I don't think my audience is so gullible, nor
do I disrespect my audience so much that now
I'm going to say this behavior is endorsed
by the Republican Party. But the point is,
their story about the left, their pedophiles
and all this different, it's we've got to do
something to not allow them to continue repeating
that, because it's the type of thing where you go,
no, no, we're not. And they go, Wow, that's
exactly what the pedophiles would be doing.
They would be denying it. There's got
to be some way out of this nonsense. And
there are too many of these stories about right
wingers to go unnoticed at this point in time.